Hey guys, I'm Shawn Hayes here with Jason Bateman and Will Arnett, and we do a show called Smart List, and it's one of us brings on a guest that the other two don't know about it, and it's a surprise. Oh my God. Are you late for something? Honestly. What's wrong? I'm telling people who haven't heard the show.
嘿大家，我是肖恩·海耶斯，和杰森·贝特曼以及威尔·阿奈特在一起，我们做了一个叫《Smart List》的节目，节目形式是我们其中一人请来一位另外两人都不知道的嘉宾，这是一个惊喜。天哪。你是不是迟到了？说真的。怎么了？我是在告诉那些还没听过这个节目的人。
People have just turned it off hearing that. All right. And by the way, why do we need that people know what they have just clicked on? We don't need to repeat. Some people don't know what they're clicking on, man. Can you imagine how drunk some people must be? Well, that's true. They're loaded.
人们听到这个就已经关掉了。好吧。顺便问一下，为什么我们需要让人们知道他们刚点了什么？我们不需要重复。有些人不知道他们在点什么，伙计。你能想象有些人喝得有多醉吗？嗯，那是真的。他们喝高了。
They've had a couple and they're like, and they hit it by mistake. They butt dialed the podcast. Well, they better not throw up on our faces. You're listening to Smart List. Yeah, don't throw up. Smart. List. Smart.
他们喝了几杯，然后就像，他们不小心点到了。他们误触了播客。好吧，他们最好别吐在我们脸上。你正在收听的是《Smart List》。是的，别吐。Smart。List。Smart。
List. Smart. List. Smart. List. Smart. List. Guys, I feel like we're stretched out real good right now.
List。Smart。List。Smart。List。Smart。List。伙计们，我觉得我们现在伸展得很好。
I'm feeling, I'm ready for the game. Wait, Will, Will, what are you really doing? I'm just looking up some stuff. I just, you know, I'm just, I'm getting ready to go. Oh, it's your guest. Right. Right. He's my guest.
我感觉，我已经为比赛做好准备了。等等，威尔，威尔，你到底在做什么？我只是在查一些东西。我只是，你知道，我只是在准备出发。哦，是你的嘉宾。对。对。他是我的嘉宾。
And so this is prepping on our time. No, here's the thing. It's like, how do you, how do you save it for the guest, save it for the guest? How do you, how do you introduce it when you're thinking about somebody who's like, you want to think about what's the best way to introduce them? What's the best way to do them justice and, and to honor? It's all stuff that should have happened about an hour ago at the latest. No, no.
所以这是在占用我们的时间做准备。不，问题是这样的。就像，你怎么，你怎么为嘉宾保留它，为嘉宾保留它？当你想到一个像，你想考虑介绍他们的最好方式是什么时，你怎么，你怎么介绍它？什么是对他们公正并，并给予尊重的最好方式？这些都是最晚应该在一小时前就完成的事情。不，不。
Well, I'll tell you what, in lieu of. Wait, how do you say it? L-I-E-U, in lieu, in lieu. Uh-oh. Here comes the French. On lieu. By the way, you know, I had a dream last night that I was speaking full French and somebody said, the worst part of this, before you roll your eyes, get ready to roll your eyes
好吧，我告诉你，代替。等等，你怎么说？L-I-E-U，in lieu，in lieu。噢哦。法语来了。On lieu。顺便说一下，你知道，我昨晚做梦梦见我在说流利的法语，有人说，这部分最糟糕的是，在你翻白眼之前，准备好翻白眼吧
at this part. I was in a room full of people. There was somebody there. I spoke French to them. And the other people said, oh, you speak French? And I went, oh, yeah, I'm kind of fluent in French. It was the, even I was disgusted by my own reaction in the dream. Say, say, even I was disgusted by my own reaction and my dream in French.
在这部分。我在一个满是人的房间里。那里有个人。我用法语和他们说话。其他人说，哦，你会说法语？我说，哦，是的，我法语还挺流利的。那是，连我自己都对梦中自己的反应感到恶心。说，说，连我自己都对梦中用法语的反应感到恶心。
Moi-même, j'étais, c'était dégoutant à moi-même, hein. Wow. Alors. So listen. Sounds like a real hockey player, yeah. This, um, this guest that we have on, on this- Are we doing this right now? Are we in our podcast right now?
Moi-même, j'étais, c'était dégoutant à moi-même, hein. 哇。Alors。所以听着。听起来像个真正的曲棍球运动员，是的。这个，嗯，我们请来的这位嘉宾，在这个——我们现在在做这个吗？我们现在在我们的播客里吗？
This is the show. We're already in the podcast. That's what's so great about the podcast space, as somebody told me it's called, is that we're always in it. The second we're, we're just, we're in it. It's a space. We're in it. Yeah.
这就是节目。我们已经在播客里了。这就是播客空间最棒的地方，正如有人告诉我的那样，我们总是身处其中。我们一进入，我们就在里面了。这是一个空间。我们在里面。是的。
It's just so conversational, right Will? I know it is. It's just like you and I are just, we're just talking. Sean's like on a party line, right? Yeah. And we were kids. Sure. Shut up.
这太像对话了，对吧威尔？我知道。就像你和我只是，我们只是在聊天。肖恩就像在派对线上，对吧？是的。我们小时候。当然。闭嘴。
This person is a, this person is an American icon. An American institution in their own right. This person has 14 number one hits. What? 14. Yeah. Billboard hits. This person is a, is a writer.
这个人是，这个人是美国偶像。他们本身就是一种美国机构。这个人有14首冠军单曲。什么？14首。是的。公告牌热门歌曲。这个人是，是一个作家。
This person is a, a singer. This person is a performer. This person is sneaky hilarious. This person is done, done, done, Mr. Brad Paisley, Brad Paisley, Sean, hello, Brad. Jason, I've always wanted to hang with you and talk Dodgers. So I'm hoping that's what we can do. This is starting off great. This is great.
这个人是，一位歌手。这个人是一位表演者。这个人极其搞笑。这个人已经，已经，已经，布拉德·派斯利先生，布拉德·派斯利，肖恩，你好，布拉德。杰森，我一直想和你一起玩，聊聊道奇队。所以我希望这就是我们能做的。这开始得太棒了。这太棒了。
Guys, you can go ahead and shut down. Have you two never been to a baseball game together? Well, we've been there at the same time, but we didn't actually drive in the same car or anything. How often do you go there? How many games do you get to? I probably get to 15 or 20 a year. Wow.
伙计们，你们可以继续关掉了。你们两个从来没有一起去看过棒球比赛吗？嗯，我们同时在那里过，但我们并没有真的开同一辆车什么的。你们多久去一次？你们一年能看多少场比赛？我大概一年去15到20次。哇。
Why don't, why don't we carpool or something or get snacks together? That's great. I'm a decent guy. You're, you're, yeah, let's do it. Will, tell him, Sean. You know what? I'll tell you, Brad, it's great to see you by the way. Thank you so much for coming over.
为什么不，为什么我们不拼车或者一起买零食呢？那太棒了。我是个不错的人。你是，你是，是的，我们做吧。威尔，告诉他，肖恩。你知道吗？我告诉你，布拉德，顺便说一下，见到你真好。非常感谢你过来。
Yeah. Whatever, whatever, Will. So Sean and I. Wait, Will and Jason, do you know that Brad and I play this zoom mafia game with a bunch of people like once, twice a week, every week. Come on. Yeah. There's a zoom, there's zoom games.
是的。随便吧，随便吧，威尔。所以肖恩和我。等等，威尔和杰森，你们知道布拉德和我每周一两次和一群人玩这个Zoom黑手党游戏吗？得了吧。是的。有Zoom，有Zoom游戏。
Oh, it's fun. There's zoom mafia. It's a lot of fun. Okay. Who else is in the zoom mafia? Now I want to know. We haven't really talked about this. It's kind of a circle of trust thing.
哦，很有趣。有Zoom黑手党。非常有趣。好的。还有谁在Zoom黑手党里？现在我想知道。我们还没真正谈过这个。这算是一种信任圈的东西。
Are we allowed to talk about it? Oh, maybe we're not. How about initials and then we can guess. We can cut it. We can cut it. If we have, if we have regrets, we can cut it. Well, there's, it's a lot of the groundlings. My wife sent it, but you know, a lot of the, a lot of the groundlings and, and it's, it's
我们被允许谈论它吗？哦，也许我们不能。首字母怎么样，然后我们可以猜。我们可以剪掉。我们可以剪掉。如果我们有，如果我们有遗憾，我们可以剪掉。嗯，有很多Groundlings的人。我妻子送的，但你知道，很多，很多Groundlings的人，而且，而且它
a lot of fun. It's actually something we tried when this began because we were doing these games at Kevin Nielsen and Kevin and Susan Nielsen's house in person and having a ball. And then we had this idea. It's like, well, maybe it'll work on zoom and it actually does. Yeah. It's super fun. Is Sean any good at it, Brad?
很有趣。这实际上是我们开始时尝试的东西，因为我们当时在凯文·尼尔森和凯文与苏珊·尼尔森家里亲自玩这些游戏，玩得很开心。然后我们有了这个想法。就像，嗯，也许它在Zoom上也能行，而且确实可以。是的。超级有趣。肖恩在里面表现好吗，布拉德？
And I know you'll be honest. No. Do you have to talk like a mafia person? Like you, you just like back your hair, Jason. You talk like you did when you were 10. Jason, have you. Yeah. Now you've played a mafia.
我知道你会诚实的。不。你必须像黑手党那样说话吗？就像你，你只是像那样梳理你的头发，杰森。你说话就像你10岁时那样。杰森，你有。是的。现在你玩过黑手党了。
You played a doc worker in Philly before, right? What was his name? Yeah. That was a, I believe it was called Philly boy. Can you give us a little bit of that? Can you give us a little bit? Boy, it's, it's been so long because, you know, there is a difference between a New York accent and a Philly accent.
你以前在费城演过码头工人，对吧？他叫什么名字？是的。那是一个，我相信它叫费城男孩。你能给我们来一点那个吗？你能给我们来一点吗？天哪，已经过去太久了，因为，你知道，纽约口音和费城口音是有区别的。
I'm not sure you know that. Can't wait to hear the difference. What's the difference? I don't know what that difference is, but that's what I was being screamed at while I was doing, doing the movie because I was missing it. Um, you feel like after all these years that you, maybe you forgot about it. Oh God. Wow.
我不确定你知道这一点。迫不及待想听听区别。有什么区别？我不知道那区别是什么，但这就是我在拍电影时被大喊大叫的内容，因为我没掌握好。嗯，你觉得这么多年后，你，也许你忘了它。哦，天哪。哇。
Drop that, drop that pallet over here, just put it down to drive the forklift. That's real. That's actually really good. Jason. Well, I think we just lost our listener. No. But, uh, well, what I was going to say was first, just getting back to the baseball, Brad, you have to understand the first time I went to a Dodger game with, with Jason,
把那个，把那个托盘扔到这里，把它放下，去开叉车。那是真的。那真的很好。杰森。嗯，我想我们刚刚失去了我们的听众。不。但是，嗯，我想说的是，首先，回到棒球，布拉德，你必须明白我第一次和杰森去看道奇队比赛时，
I was really excited because he's a big Dodger fan. This is such a terrible story. It's, it's meaning it's hurtful. It's not hurtful. First of all, well, to me, it was, it was, I'll never forget it. It was my worst nightmare. It's not the first one. The first game is not what you think it is.
我真的很兴奋，因为他是道奇队的铁杆粉丝。这是一个如此糟糕的故事。它，它意味着它是伤人的。它不伤人。首先，威尔，对我来说，它是，它是，我永远不会忘记它。这是我最糟糕的噩梦。这不是第一次。第一场比赛不是你想象的那样。
I'll tell that. The real thing, the story here was we get to the game, parks in his spot and Jason opens up the glove box and there he's got two little sort of old school transistor radios that you, with a one earpiece and he hands one to me and I go, what's this? He goes, yeah, we listened to the game the whole time. Oh, yeah, yeah, there's not a lot of talking. So we get to the game, the whole experience and he puts his radio in and he's just zoned out.
我会讲那个。真正的事情，这里的故事是我们到了比赛现场，他在他的车位停车，杰森打开了手套箱，那里有两台那种老式的晶体管收音机，带有一个耳机，他递给我一个，我问，这是什么？他说，是的，我们全程听比赛。哦，是的，是的，没多少话。所以我们到了比赛现场，整个体验，他戴上他的收音机，他就进入状态了。
He's watching the game. I'm like, yeah, baseball game with a guy and now we're not even, there's no chitchat. Maybe the seventh inning like, Hey, you want to get some, yeah, we're not going to sit there and visit for three hours. I'll bet you he doesn't do that with other people. That's a, there's a good chance. I'd never do that to you, Brad, ever. No, we would have meaningful discussions during the game.
他在看比赛。我心想，是的，和一个人看棒球比赛，现在我们甚至，没有闲聊。也许第七局的时候，嘿，你想买点什么，是的，我们不会坐在那里闲聊三个小时。我敢打赌他不会和别人那样做。那是一个，很有可能。我永远不会那样对你，布拉德，永远。不，我们在比赛中会有有意义的讨论。
Sure we would. We get there early, right? We'd stay late. We'd help them clean up. Unbelievable. I mean, it's impossible, this environment and that, but the next one of the other times I've been with, I've been, we've been a few times. One time I went, Jason had a, he used to take his glove with him to catch the odd, you know,
当然我们会。我们早点到，对吧？我们会待到很晚。我们会帮他们清理。难以置信。我是说，这环境是不可能的，但是下一次，我还有几次和，我们去过几次。有一次我去的时候，杰森带了，他过去常带着他的手套去接那个，你知道，
foul ball. You gotta stay ready. And we joined the seventh inning. He got to put it on the seat between us. I picked up the mitt and we were just absentmindedly just chitchatting. The game starts at this point, we were chitchatting full disclosure and Dave Roberts, who at the time was playing for the Dodgers hits a foul ball. And we both stand, it's coming towards us and it's coming right towards Jason, right
界外球。你得保持准备。我们在第七局加入了。他把它放在我们之间的座位上。我拿起了手套，我们只是心不在焉地闲聊。比赛在这一点上开始了，我们当时在全盘闲聊，而当时为道奇队效力的戴夫·罗伯茨打出了一个界外球。我们俩都站了起来，它朝我们飞来，它正朝杰森飞来，正
towards him. And at the last second I reach in front of him with his own glove and snagged the foul ball. You caught a foul ball? I caught it in front of Jason's hands. Like he's got the glove for one batter. I got it for one batter and I snag it and then I'm up on the jumbotron like, you know, like a hero.
朝他飞来。在最后一秒，我用他自己的手套在他面前伸手，抓住了那个界外球。你接到了一个界外球？我在杰森的手前接住了它。就像他有一个击球手的手套。我有一个击球手的手套，我抓住了它，然后我上了大屏幕，你知道，像个英雄。
Like you hear about heroes all the time, but this is a real hero. And then I look and everybody's like, yeah. When I look at Jason's face, I looked through to him and he's so sunken and sad and upset. Usually the person you're standing next to after you catch a foul ball is he's got nothing but high fives loaded for you and I just couldn't have been sadder. The disappointment losing from his body. I don't understand. You took the ball.
就像你一直听到的英雄一样，但这才是真正的英雄。然后我看了看，每个人都在说，耶。当我看着杰森的脸时，我透过他看去，他看起来如此沮丧、悲伤和难过。通常你接住界外球后站在你旁边的人，他只会为你准备好击掌，而我简直不能再悲伤了。他身体里流露出的失望。我不明白。你拿走了球。
You handed me the mitt back. I did. I've still got the ball. And I think you said, are you good to go? I think you were ready to leave, right? He was confused. He was confused how long the third period was going to last. Yeah.
你把手套还给我了。我做了。球还在我这儿。我想你说，你准备好了吗？我想你当时准备离开了，对吧？他很困惑。他很困惑第三局会持续多久。是的。
We can keep it up. Yeah. He wanted to get out of there. You know. Anyway, so that's that's what you got to look forward to, Brad. I'm excited for you. I will have fun. Yeah, we will.
我们可以保持下去。是的。他想离开那里。你知道。总之，这就是你所期待的，布拉德。我为你感到兴奋。我会玩得开心的。是的，我们会。
I think it'd be great. And we'll do lots of talking. Brad, can you tell us? Cause by the way, I was going to probably see you. I'm not going to see you tonight, but I'm going to see you. You're not going to be there tonight? Wait. No, I can't.
我觉得那会很棒。我们会聊很多。布拉德，你能告诉我们吗？因为顺便说一下，我本来可能会见到你。我今晚见不到你，但我会见到你。你今晚不去那里吗？等等。不，我不能。
How are you guys all friends? How do you guys know Brad Paisley for God's sake? Where have I been? You're wrong with my phone number, you dicks, we'll exchange and we're done and then it'll be great. You can be part of this magic. Yeah, but it's my job to make them jealous for the next year or so. We're just you and I.
你们怎么都是朋友？看在上帝的份上，你们怎么认识布拉德·派斯利的？我一直在哪儿？你们记错了我的电话号码，你们这些混蛋，我们会交换号码，然后就完成了，那会很棒。你可以成为这个魔法的一部分。是的，但我的工作是在接下来的一年左右让他们嫉妒。我们只是你和我。
We're moving in. Yeah. We're going to be like dressing in blue and white the whole time and yeah, face painting each other. You guys go, go start without me. I'll catch up. But listen, how do you guys know each other? Sean and I are through our friends that we do Mafia with and then Will and I are.
我们要搬进去了。是的。我们要一直穿着蓝色和白色的衣服，是的，互相画脸。你们去，去开始吧，不用等我。我会赶上的。但是听着，你们是怎么认识彼此的？肖恩和我通过我们一起玩黑手党的朋友认识，然后威尔和我。
Oh, sorry. Don't send anything. The chunks got something in his mouth, man, can you wait till we're done doing the podcast where you start snacking? Are we on a break? I got to stay fueled up, man. You have any idea what I'm doing over here on a physical. It's obvious what you're doing.
哦，抱歉。别发任何东西。那家伙嘴里有东西，伙计，你能在我们做完播客后再开始吃零食吗？我们在休息吗？我得保持能量，伙计。你知道我在这边做身体训练是什么意思吗？很明显你在做什么。
You're tanning bed and you're like, look at you. My tanning bed is called Planet Earth, Brad and CrossFit and tanning bed at this point. It's unbelievable. Yeah, get a job. Most people would wear a darker color, but Will's got bright, white on to show off the tan. Yeah, makes a tan pop. I knew there was, when I was putting this shirt on, cause I didn't have a shirt on for
你在晒黑床，你就像，看看你。我的晒黑床叫地球，布拉德，还有CrossFit和晒黑床，目前为止。这太不可思议了。是的，找份工作吧。大多数人会穿深色一点的颜色，但威尔穿了亮白色来炫耀他的晒黑。是的，让晒黑更突出。我知道有，当我穿上这件衬衫时，因为我大部分时间都没穿衬衫
most of the day. Here we go. Here we go. I thought I am running the, I am really leaving myself open and then I thought, you know what, fuck it. Let them take their shots. I'm going to let them punch themselves out and then I'm going to come back for them. Wait a minute.
这一天。开始了。开始了。我想我正在运行，我真的让自己处于开放状态，然后我想，你知道吗，去他的。让他们开火吧。我要让他们打到精疲力竭，然后我会回来找他们。等等。
I have to jump in here. Okay. Brad, I saw your, the concert, it was amazing. Thank you. And will you tell people how that came together and like what you did and by the way, the speech that you gave when you were playing the guitar, like all the kids and it was just so moving and inspiring. This was one of the graduation shows?
我得插一句。好的。布拉德，我看了你的，演唱会，太棒了。谢谢。你能告诉大家那是怎么促成的，以及你做了什么，顺便说一下，你弹吉他时发表的演讲，就像所有的孩子，那真是太感人、太鼓舞人心了。这是毕业演出之一吗？
No, actually what this was was Bud Light sponsored us to set our whole, like basically we set our whole tour up, an entire arena show, 60 foot video wall and then spent three days setting it up, everybody wearing masks until the show started. All the band members had to be 10 feet apart and we did our show live via YouTube and Facebook and Bud Light paid for it and it was really neat because it was like the only strange part is in between every song, like we had our lights, we had our video wall, we had everything, but in between each song, it was no applause obviously. Yeah.
不，实际上这是百威淡啤赞助我们设置我们的整个，就像基本上我们设置了我们的整个巡演，整个竞技场演出，60英尺的视频墙，然后花了三天时间设置它，每个人都戴着口罩直到演出开始。所有的乐队成员必须保持10英尺的距离，我们通过YouTube和Facebook现场直播了我们的演出，百威淡啤为此买单，这真的很棒，因为就像唯一奇怪的部分是每首歌之间，就像我们有我们的灯光，我们有我们的视频墙，我们有所有东西，但在每首歌之间，显然没有掌声。是的。
Every now and then I was like, browbeat my sound guy. Welcome to Will's world. Yeah. Yeah. Right. And Bud Light paid for it in Bud Light, right? They paid for it in Bud Light. They've been doing that for many tours that way.
每隔一段时间我就像，训斥我的音响师。欢迎来到威尔的世界。是的。是的。对。百威淡啤为此付了钱，用百威淡啤，对吧？他们用百威淡啤付了钱。他们以那种方式做了很多巡演。
So when you usually would say like, Detroit, you know, between, do you, what do you scream? Is it YouTube? YouTube. Yeah. That'll work. You can also, you know, internet. You can go. Internet.
所以当你通常会说像，底特律，你知道，在中间，你，你喊什么？是YouTube吗？YouTube。是的。那行得通。你也可以，你知道，互联网。你可以去。互联网。
Digital. So what's that like? So you're at a full blown stadium arena or whatever and you're literally looking out to an empty house. It's, I would imagine it'd be like a reoccurring nightmare for you. But it was shot so beautifully. It looked so cool. Plenty of room for camera moves out there, you know.
数字。那是什么感觉？所以你在一个成熟的体育场竞技场或什么地方，你真的在看着一个空荡荡的房子。我，我想象那会像是一个反复出现的噩梦。但它拍得太美了。看起来太酷了。外面有足够的空间进行摄像机移动，你知道。
Yeah. We had a drone flying around it. Sure. I'll bet you did. You can't do that with an audience. Yeah. I mean, anybody well could, I guess, but it was really weird because it was normal in the middle of this show and the spotlight's on and the lights are doing their thing.
是的。我们有一架无人机在周围飞。当然。我敢打赌你有。你不能和观众一起那样做。是的。我是说，任何人都可以，我想，但这真的很奇怪，因为在演出中间很正常，聚光灯亮着，灯光在做它们的事。
And then you kind of forget about the audience anyway, half the time when you're playing in the middle of a song. And then after the song, it's like, well, we suck. Yeah. Nobody cared. It was just so dead silent. It's not how it was viewed at all. I mean, it was.
然后你无论如何都会忘记观众，当你在一首歌中间演奏时。然后在那首歌之后，就像，嗯，我们糟透了。是的。没人关心。它只是死一般的寂静。它根本不是那样被观看的。我是说，它是。
So Brad, you do this huge concert that's put over the internet and it's massive and it's weird because you're doing it in front of this, you know, no audience and stuff and that sensation, how weird that is. Take us back to your first tour. What was that? Well, where was it? What was that? How'd that come together?
所以布拉德，你做了这个巨大的演唱会，通过互联网播放，它是巨大的，而且很奇怪，因为你在，你知道，没有观众等等的情况下做它，那种感觉，那有多奇怪。带我们回到你的第一次巡演。那是什么？嗯，它在哪里？那是什么？那是怎么促成的？
That was really interesting because when you're new, you do everything free. So because you don't have an audience. So I had a struggling first single that took 37 weeks to get to number 12 on the Billboard chart. First single. It was a good song, but you know, it is. It was, we were begging and borrowing and stealing every bit of airplay we could get. But my second single ended up changing everything and it was my first number one song.
那真的很有趣，因为当你是个新人时，你做所有事情都是免费的。所以因为你没有观众。所以我有一个挣扎的第一首单曲，花了37周才在公告牌排行榜上达到第12名。第一首单曲。那是一首好歌，但你知道，它是。我们当时在乞求、借用和窃取我们能得到的每一分播放量。但我的第二首单曲最终改变了一切，它是我第一首冠军歌曲。
It was actually the first, like it was kind of a tight ship at that time in country music. They weren't letting anybody new in. And it was the first number one single from a new artist in like five or six years. Wow. Wow. And it was called He Didn't Have to Be and it was written about my best friend who's a stepfather and it was written about a dad who is the dad he doesn't have to be. And anyway, it just generated so much and I ended up winning awards for that and getting
它实际上是第一首，就像当时乡村音乐界是一个紧密的圈子。他们不让任何新人进来。这是五六年里第一首来自新艺人的冠军单曲。哇。哇。它叫《He Didn't Have to Be》，它是关于我最好的朋友，他是一个继父，它是关于一个父亲，他是一个他不必成为的父亲。总之，它产生了如此多的影响，我最终因此赢得了奖项并获得了
nominated for a lot of things and that changed everything. And what year was that about? It went number one in 19, it came out in 1999. I think it went number one in like January of 2000. So you know, 20 years ago. And but that first tour, it's like, I had, here's what's crazy. I have the same band today that I had then. From that first tour?
很多提名的东西，那改变了一切。那是哪一年？它在19年获得冠军，它在1999年发行。我想它在2000年1月左右获得冠军。所以你知道，20年前。但是那第一次巡演，就像，我有，这是疯狂的。我今天有和那时一样的乐队。从那第一次巡演开始？
Yeah. Same six guys are with me. That's so great. And we've been through it all. I mean, when my, when I met Kim, my wife, she came out on the road with us and we had to kick somebody out of their bunk because it was a 12 bunk bus and we had 12 people on it, 12 bunks were taken. So she ended up getting like the keyboard player's bunk and he had to sleep on the couch in
是的。同样的六个人和我在一起。那太棒了。我们经历了一切。我是说，当我的，当我遇到金，我的妻子时，她和我们一起上路，我们不得不把某人踢出他们的铺位，因为那是一辆12个铺位的巴士，我们上面有12个人，12个铺位都被占了。所以她最终得到了像键盘手的铺位，他不得不睡在沙发上
the front of the bunk. That was that first tour when she came out. And then she remembers when we got our trailer that you could pull behind the bus with gear in it. We weren't renting things anymore. And that was huge. So that's kind of nice that she saw us go from that to... Brad, I toured with Kenny Rogers.
铺位的前面。那是她出来时的第一次巡演。然后她记得当我们得到我们的拖车时，你可以把它拉在巴士后面，里面装着装备。我们不再租东西了。那太大了。所以很高兴她看到我们从那走到……布拉德，我和肯尼·罗杰斯一起巡演过。
Yes, you're hearing that correctly. How? What? Doing what? What were you doing with him? Christmas elf and it was his Christmas tour and I slept on those buses too. And I hated it. I don't understand how you can do that for 20 years.
是的，你听得没错。怎么会？什么？做什么？你和他一起做什么？圣诞精灵，那是他的圣诞巡演，我也睡在那些巴士上。我讨厌它。我不明白你怎么能那样做20年。
I mean, do you don't mind being on the road and living in those quarters on those buses? It was just... We do it different. See, Nashville is so centrally located. We don't have to go six months. Oh, okay. Okay. It's like leave Thursday night, be home Saturday night.
我是说，你不介意在路上生活在那些巴士的那些空间里吗？这只是……我们做得不同。你看，纳什维尔位置非常中心。我们不必去六个月。哦，好的。好的。就像周四晚上离开，周六晚上回家。
Oh, then forget it. And that's kind of fun. Yeah. I mean, and yeah, it's all right. You're not supposed to go to the bathroom on the bus. Is that right? Do I have that right? Not true.
哦，那就算了。那挺有趣的。是的。我是说，而且是的，没关系。你不应该在巴士上上厕所。是这样吗？我没弄错吧？不真实。
And in a lot of the lease buses, that's true. In ours, we have what's called a grinder. And it's... So do we. It goes... And it... Yeah, there you go. Is that the one you swipe?
在很多租赁巴士上，那是真的。在我们的车里，我们有叫研磨机的东西。它是……我们也有。它发出……然后它……是的，给你。那是你刷的那一个吗？
Is that the dudes or the girls? Oh, look, and I'm asking so innocently. Yeah, it's the guys. I'm not sure. It's the guy's face. It's the guy one? Okay. It's the guy.
那是男人的还是女人的？哦，看，我问得如此天真。是的，是男人的。我不确定。那是男人的脸。是男人的那个？好的。是男人的。
And if you like somebody, you go left or do you go right? Either way on that one. Okay. You just go straight up. Yeah. Okay. Let's do this. Sorry.
如果你喜欢某人，你向左还是向右？那个无论哪种方式都可以。好的。你只是直接向上。是的。好的。我们做这个吧。抱歉。
Will's still chewing. We can hold. Hold on. We'll wait on Will. No, no. I took this opportunity because I didn't have anything to add to the grinder session. The grinder session? Yeah.
威尔还在咀嚼。我们可以等。等一下。我们会等威尔。不，不。我利用这个机会，因为我在研磨机环节没什么可补充的。研磨机环节？是的。
So explain to me what a grinder does, Brad, on the bus. Oh my God. Think of it as like a food disposal, but it's the other end of the food spectrum. Yeah. Yeah, but why would you need to grind it up? That's not the problem. It seems like you'd be agitating the odor by blending it. Well, you'd think, but it works surprisingly well.
所以向我解释一下研磨机在巴士上做什么，布拉德。哦，天哪。把它想成食物处理器，但它是食物光谱的另一端。是的。是的，但你为什么要把它磨碎？那不是问题。看起来你通过混合它会搅动气味。嗯，你会这么想，但它出奇地有效。
I think what happens is it liquefies it before it ends up in the septic tank on the bus. Will, go ahead and enjoy your balance bar. This is horrible. Will actually wanted me to ask this. He was too embarrassed to ask you. Asked me to ask you, which direction did the wheels and the bus go? Round and round, actually. Yeah.
我想发生的是它在进入巴士上的化粪池之前将其液化。威尔，继续享受你的平衡棒吧。这太可怕了。威尔实际上想让我问这个。他太尴尬了，不敢问你。让我问你，巴士上的轮子往哪个方向转？实际上是转来转去。是的。
Well done. That's our first break, everybody. Now, what about videos? What kind of lane do the videos take in today's sort of music industry? Are they helpful or are they just additive? They've been relegated to the, to the berm of the highway. We're just not even really doing them. You don't, you don't really make them anymore at all.
做得好。那是我们的第一次休息，各位。现在，视频怎么样？视频在今天的音乐产业中占据什么样的位置？它们有帮助吗，还是只是附加的？它们已经被降级到高速公路的路肩了。我们甚至真的没在做它们。你，你根本不再制作它们了。
We do them, but they don't matter like they did. Like they used to be that you'd air them on television. They don't even on television, even shows them anymore. And it's so like when you make a video, it's kind of a promotional tool and it's a little more like you want it to be something interesting to watch on Instagram more than you do, more than you care about. Do you pay for it or is the record company pay for it? How do you split it with them?
我们做它们，但它们不像以前那样重要了。就像它们过去在电视上播放一样。现在甚至连电视节目都不再播放它们了。所以当你制作一个视频时，它更像是一个促销工具，它更像你希望它成为Instagram上值得观看的东西，而不是你关心的。你付钱还是唱片公司付钱？你如何与他们分成？
You would think that it would be a relevant and an attractive piece of media considering yeah, all the like Instagram watching and the tick talking, whatever the hell is going on. I mean, to watch your favorite artists sing the song that you love there on your phone, you're listening to it already on your phone. You would think. And in fact, isn't there, there's, I was watching my daughter, she had some, one of these pop stars singing a song on the, on her iTunes and on the iTunes, on the iTunes, you could
你会认为它会是一个相关且有吸引力的媒体片段，考虑到是的，所有像Instagram观看和TikTok，不管到底发生了什么。我是说，在你的手机上观看你最喜欢的艺人演唱你喜欢的歌，你已经在手机上听它了。你会这么想。事实上，不是有吗，有，我当时在看我女儿，她有，这些流行歌星之一在她的iTunes上唱歌，在iTunes上，在iTunes上，你可以
touch the screen and you see the, the artist might not necessarily be singing the song, but they're doing some other stuff or wouldn't, what, what does that call? Is that like today's video? Uh, yeah, I'm not sure what that is necessarily because I'm as old as you. But I think that I see Spotify did something awesome for a while. They did vertical videos. And so you'd hold your phone and it would be, you had to make it specifically for Spotify. And when you were listening to the song, you could do that.
触摸屏幕，你看到，艺人可能不一定在唱那首歌，但他们在做其他事情，或者不会，那叫什么？那是今天的视频吗？嗯，是的，我不确定那是什么，因为我和你一样老。但我认为我看到Spotify有一段时间做了一些很棒的事情。他们做了垂直视频。所以你拿着手机，它会是，你必须专门为Spotify制作它。当你听那首歌时，你可以那样做。
And it's a video of the artist made that's just for Spotify that was like straight up and down. That's what it is. Some artists, it still comes up when you on Spotify. I like that. I think that's cool. But you'll get more views on the Lyric video these days, half the time than you will on something like 300,000 dollars.
这是一个艺人制作的视频，只是为了Spotify，它是直上直下的。就是那样。有些艺人，当你在Spotify上时，它仍然会出现。我喜欢那个。我觉得那很酷。但这些天，歌词视频的观看次数往往比那种30万美元的视频还要多。
Those things are huge. Yeah. What's a Lyric video? It's basically the bouncing ball. It's like the words go across the screen as. Yeah. So everybody can learn it. Yeah.
那些东西太大了。是的。什么是歌词视频？它基本上是弹跳球。就像文字在屏幕上移动，当。是的。所以每个人都可以学习它。是的。
But with, with a visual of you, of you performing the song as well. No. It's just the words. Oh, yeah. I get another reason you should learn how to read, Jason. I mean, right there. Yeah. It sounds exhausting.
但伴随着，伴随着你，你表演这首歌的视觉效果。不。只是文字。哦，是的。我明白了，你应该学习如何阅读的另一个原因，杰森。我是说，就在那里。是的。听起来很累人。
Yeah. It's not worth honestly. Wait a minute though. Are you, so Brad, are you saying that and Jason, are you both saying that the video, like making a music video is, is required, but kind of pointless at the same time? Like, because I, you know, everybody for years was like, is MTV, is MTV going to come back with videos? Remember BH1 MTV, all they would play in music videos and we would associate, I would give
是的。老实说不值得。等等。你是，所以布拉德，你是说，杰森，你们俩都在说，视频，就像制作音乐视频是必须的，但同时又有点毫无意义？因为我，你知道，每个人多年来都在说，MTV，MTV会带着视频回来吗？记得BH1 MTV，他们只会播放音乐视频，我们会联想，我会给
us something to associate the song with and now you have just the song, but I can't imagine like, well, Will, like you're saying too is like, it seems like it's just a viable outlet to promote the song and the label would have, would back it. Little mini movies. They were fantastic. And they were so engaging, just as little pieces of sort of narrative that it got to the point, so I understand it, that bands had to be told and they were required to at least for two or three seconds in every video, be playing their instruments.
我们一些东西来联想这首歌，现在你只有这首歌，但我无法想象，就像，威尔，就像你说的也是，它看起来只是一个推广这首歌的可行渠道，唱片公司会支持它。小电影。它们太棒了。它们太吸引人了，只是作为叙事的小片段，以至于到了那个地步，所以我理解它，乐队必须被告知，并且他们被要求至少在每个视频中，有两三秒钟在演奏他们的乐器。
Like you had to show, you had to, it was like a legal requirement that you had to be playing your instruments for like three, otherwise you can, you know, walk around and be jumping in pools or whatever the hell the video is, but you'd literally had to be seeing, playing your instruments, seeing the song for a little bit because they became such engaging little tiny mini movies. Yeah, that's probably, that's probably the case. I mean, in our town, some did better than others. I had a great run where I had some that really mattered.
就像你必须展示，你必须，就像法律要求你必须演奏你的乐器大约三秒钟，否则你可以，你知道，四处走动，在游泳池里跳来跳去，或者不管视频是什么，但你必须真的看到，演奏你的乐器，看到这首歌一会儿，因为它们变成了如此吸引人的小迷你电影。是的，那可能是，那可能是真的。我是说，在我们的城镇，有些做得比别人好。我有一段很棒的经历，我有一些真正重要的视频。
The first one that really mattered for me was that was like bigger than the song at first, which was a song kind of, I'm going to miss her, which is a funny song about fishing. And it's basically the hook of the song is, you know, Get it? The hook? Yeah. If I hit that fishing hole today, she'll be packing all her things and she'll be gone by noon chorus while I'm going to miss her, you know, and at the end of the chorus, it's
第一个对我真正重要的视频，起初比那首歌还要大，那是一首，我要想念她，这是一首关于钓鱼的有趣歌曲。它基本上是这首歌的钩子，你知道，明白吗？钩子？是的。如果我今天去那个钓鱼点，她会打包她所有的东西，中午之前她就会离开，副歌，我要想念她，你知道，在副歌结束时，它
like, oh, lookie there, I've got a bite. And so I had this idea and I went to the label and I said, I want to get, I'm going to throw the book at it and I want to hold a fake fishing tournament. Dan Patrick will be the announcer. And then second half of the song, all the wives, I'm going to have some other country singers and stuff in it. All their wives end up on the Jerry Springer show, mad at us talking about how their husbands have abandoned them.
就像，哦，看那里，我上钩了。所以我有了这个想法，我去了唱片公司，我说，我想，我要全力以赴，我想举办一场假的钓鱼比赛。丹·帕特里克将担任播音员。然后歌曲的后半部分，所有的妻子，我要让其他一些乡村歌手什么的参与进来。所有的妻子最终都上了杰瑞·斯普林格秀，对我们很生气，谈论她们的丈夫是如何抛弃她们的。
And we did all that. Like we pulled that off that things still exists. And as you can imagine, that was sort of like a watershed moment for me because I went in there and kind of called my shot. And I sort of pointed at the left field wall and I'm going to get all these people and I didn't know Jerry Springer. I didn't know Dan Patrick at the time, but I called him up and they did it. But you'd had, you'd had a fair bit of success by that point, right?
我们做了所有这些。就像我们成功做到了，那些东西仍然存在。正如你可以想象的那样，那对我来说是一个分水岭时刻，因为我走进去，有点像叫了我的球。我有点指向左外野墙，我要找所有这些人，我当时不认识杰瑞·斯普林格。我当时不认识丹·帕特里克，但我给他们打了电话，他们就做了。但你当时已经取得了不少成功，对吧？
Couple of, I'd had, I'd had two number ones at that point. Yeah. That'll do it. What was that feeling? Cause as I alluded to when, when, uh, when I did the intro that you've had, I think it's 14, uh, number one. It's 22, but it's fine. Yeah.
几个，我当时已经有两个冠军了。是的。那就可以了。那是什么感觉？因为正如我提到的，当，当，当我做介绍时，你有，我想是14个，呃，冠军。是22个，但没关系。是的。
A whole nother touchdown. Wow. Um, we all know who, but I mean 22. So, so 22. So now it's kind of like, yeah, 22, but I mean that first number one, was that, that moment, would you remember that moment of like, It was great. Cause here's what it was.
又一个达阵。哇。嗯，我们都知道是谁，但我是说22个。所以，所以22个。所以现在它有点像，是的，22个，但我是说第一个冠军，那是那个时刻，你还记得那个时刻吗？那太棒了。因为这就是它。
It's that first song I was telling you about that was like, I didn't even think it'd be a single. It was this really heartfelt song about the plight of sort of a stepdad trying to sort of be everything his kid needs. And we were in a battle to try and get number one. The way number one's work, it's like anything in our industry and your industry too, where it's just politics and it's a game and it's who got the most spins that week and a lot of times that's manipulated and purchased and, you know, it's flyaways and giveaways
那是第一首歌，我告诉过你的那首，就像，我甚至没想过它会成为单曲。这是一首非常感人的歌，关于继父试图成为孩子需要的一切的困境。我们当时在争取冠军。冠军的工作方式，就像我们行业和你们行业里的任何事情一样，它只是政治，它是一场游戏，它是谁那周获得了最多的播放量，很多时候那是被操纵和购买的，你知道，它是赠品和赠品
and all these things to get it there and, and, uh, we were in a just knocked down drag out battle for number one, the week it was going and I went to WSM to be on the radio on a Monday morning, which is the oldest radio station in country music. It's the place where the opera started in the twenties and it's AM and I went and did an interview with the woman that was the DJ there and she's still on to this day. And we were talking about the song and she's like, I really hope this goes number one today. I know you guys are trying and I'm driving home from the Grand Ole Opera House and I'm on the interstate and I'm, and I'm listening to WWVA driving down the road and she comes
以及所有这些东西来达到那个目标，而且，呃，我们当时在为冠军进行一场激烈的战斗，那周它就要发生了，我周一早上去了WSM电台做节目，那是乡村音乐中最古老的电台。那是歌剧在二十年代开始的地方，它是AM电台，我去采访了那里的DJ女士，她至今仍在工作。我们当时在谈论这首歌，她说，我真的希望今天这首歌能获得冠军。我知道你们在努力，我正从大奥普里剧院开车回家，我在州际公路上，我正在，我正在听WWVA开车，她出现
on and says, Brad Paisley, if you're listening, your song just went number one on the radio station. That's incredible. That was, I had to like pull over. I was like, I couldn't keep driving. I'll bet you that the second number one felt pretty good too, because if you had any doubt that maybe the first one was like, ah, you know, maybe I'm a one hit wonder or maybe I'll never be able to do it again or whatever.
并说，布拉德·派斯利，如果你在听，你的歌刚刚在电台上获得了冠军。那太不可思议了。那是，我不得不像靠边停车。我当时想，我无法继续开车了。我敢打赌第二个冠军感觉也相当不错，因为如果你有任何怀疑，也许第一个就像，啊，你知道，也许我是一首热门歌曲的奇迹，或者也许我永远无法再做到这一点，或者其他什么。
Like boom, did it again. And then the third one is like, oh, I'm going to be around a while now. Well, all of them were a struggle. They were all a struggle in the beginning. Like the first three weren't, it wasn't like I set the world on fire. My third single went to 16 and died. It was still kind of a hit, but it didn't have the legs to go all the way up the chart. Sort of like me.
就像砰，又做到了。然后第三个就像，哦，我现在要待上一段时间了。嗯，所有这些都是一场挣扎。它们在开始时都是一场挣扎。就像前三个不是，不像我让世界着火了。我的第三首单曲到了16名就死了。它仍然算是一首热门歌曲，但它没有后劲一直冲上排行榜。有点像我。
I don't have the legs either. Never have. Your legs are beautiful, Brad. Don't say that. Thanks. I appreciate that. So that one went number one and then the one after it, we struggled to get it to number two and it went all the way to number two and it wasn't really set in the world on fire.
我也没有后劲。从来没有。你的腿很美，布拉德。别那么说。谢谢。我很感激。所以那首获得了冠军，然后它之后的那首，我们努力让它达到第二名，它一直到了第二名，它并没有真正让世界着火。
And that's when I went into my record label after that fourth single and I'd had two number ones, but every other song was sort of a lot of work and I begged them to let me release this fishing song and they just kept saying women are going to be offended by that. They're going to be so offended that you're saying you want to go fishing instead of stay with your girlfriend and it was like, I don't think they are. I think they know us and it set the world on fire in my industry and my album was like, at the time, here I was with a song that went to number two and my album was like 35 on
那就是我在第四首单曲之后走进我的唱片公司时，我已经有两个冠军了，但每一首歌都算是一项艰苦的工作，我恳求他们让我发行这首钓鱼歌，他们只是不断说女性会被那个冒犯。她们会因为你说你想去钓鱼而不是和女朋友待在一起而感到如此冒犯，就像，我不认为她们会。我认为她们了解我们，它在我的行业里让世界着火了，我的专辑当时就像，那时我有一首达到第二名的歌，我的专辑就像在
the chart. My album went from 35 to two in three weeks when the fishing song came out. Wow. Have you gone fishing with Kimmel? No, I never have, but he goes up and goes fly fishing with like Huey Lewis every year I know. Do you do fly fishing your thing or do you do a different kind of fishing? I can.
排行榜上第35名。当钓鱼歌出来时，我的专辑在三周内从35名升到了第2名。哇。你和坎摩尔一起去钓鱼过吗？不，我从来没有，但他每年都去和像休伊·刘易斯那样的人一起飞钓，我知道。你做飞钓是你的事吗，还是你做另一种钓鱼？我可以。
I'm not as good at it, but I love it. Do you go? I've never have, but the way he talks about those trips, I'd like to learn just to go on it. You should jump on that. We should plan one and do that sometime. We were going to go, we went on like spring break together with all the kids and stuff and it was Molly's birthday and we're in this beautiful place and there was like lots
我不太擅长，但我喜欢它。你去吗？我从来没有，但他谈论那些旅行的方式，我想学习只是为了去参加。你应该加入那个。我们应该计划一次，找个时间做那个。我们本来要去的，我们和所有的孩子什么的去过春假，那是莫莉的生日，我们在一个美丽的地方，那里有像很多
of fish and Jimmy's like, anybody want to go fishing? And of course we were like, no, Jason and I did not go and Jimmy went out with the guy. Yeah, but he's getting up at four in the morning and Jack asked in three hours to whatever the fishing hole is, but I'm talking about like these are like dedicated trips where you got to like pack in with a bunch of horses and stay in a lodge and things like that. That sounds good from here, but I'd probably start whining about thread count as soon as I got up there. You know, these sheets are too rough.
鱼，吉米就像，有人想去钓鱼吗？当然我们就像，不，杰森和我没有去，吉米和那个人出去了。是的，但他早上四点起床，杰克问三个小时到不管什么钓鱼点，但我说的是像这些是专门的旅行，你必须像带着一群马进去，住在旅馆里之类的。那听起来不错，但我可能会一到那里就开始抱怨线数。你知道，这些床单太粗糙了。
My nipples are raw. Absolutely. I can get that. Brad, I have a cheesy songwriting question. So Brad, when you and I play, you know, mafia through zoom with all of our friends, Brad off the top of his head, it made me laugh. So off the top of his head, it was something like this whole town is so fucked up, a whole bunch of whores in pickup trucks, like, but like it was a whole song like in at the top
我的乳头很痛。绝对。我能理解。布拉德，我有一个俗气的歌曲创作问题。所以布拉德，当你和我玩，你知道，通过Zoom和我们所有的朋友玩黑手党时，布拉德脱口而出，这让我笑了。所以他脱口而出，就像是整个城镇都搞砸了，一群皮卡车里的妓女，就像，但就像它是一整首歌，在你的
of your head, which is so mind blowing. We did a mafia where I scored the session basically, where somebody died and we'd start singing something. Yeah. It was so funny. It was a lot of fun. Unbelievable. So how do you do that?
脑海里，这太令人震惊了。我们玩了一次黑手党，我基本上为那个环节配了乐，有人死了，我们开始唱什么东西。是的。太搞笑了。很有趣。难以置信。所以你是怎么做到的？
A and B, because I think that's remarkable. And one of the cheesiest all time questions, anybody could ask a songwriter, but I'm always intrigued because everybody has a different process, lyrics first or music first and why? I think that it could be either on the lyrics or music. It's just, for me, it's never that hard to kind of find a melody for something if I have a good idea of what a great lyric ought to be. Like if I have a good idea, a good idea is like the kind of thing that you're like, oh, man, I got to write that and the melody will find it.
A和B，因为我觉得这很了不起。这是词曲作者最常被问到的俗套问题之一，但我总是很感兴趣，因为每个人的创作过程都不同，是先有歌词还是先有旋律？为什么？我觉得歌词或旋律先来都可以。对我来说，只要我对歌词应该表达的内容有很好的构思，找到旋律从来都不是难事。就像如果我有一个好点子，好点子就是那种让你觉得“天哪，我一定要写下来”，然后旋律自然就会浮现。
But lyrics are the hard part. That's the part that you don't, you don't want, I don't like things that are cliched and feel totally just tired and retread. I love those songs. Those are my favorite. Are they? Yeah. But for help for lyrics, like do you like read poetry?
但歌词才是难点。那是你不想……我不喜欢陈词滥调，也不喜欢那些听起来疲惫不堪、老调重弹的东西。我喜欢那些歌。那是我的最爱。真的吗？是啊。但关于歌词，你会读诗吗？
Do you look at certain authors? Do you? Yeah. I mean, it can be anywhere. There's a songwriter in Nashville named John Ims who's written some big songs over the years. I saw him say something once at a writer's night, a Bluebird writer's night and it stuck with me and it was, don't expect output if you don't have input.
你会关注某些作家吗？会吗？会。我的意思是，灵感可以来自任何地方。纳什维尔有一位词曲作者叫约翰·伊姆斯（John Ims），多年来写过不少大热歌曲。有一次在“蓝鸟”创作之夜（Bluebird writer's night），我听他说过一句话，让我印象深刻，那就是：如果没有输入，就别指望有输出。
If this was a computer, you have to have input. I mean, it's like, so read and, and listen to things and watch movies and all of it. I mean, I've gotten songs from the strangest lines. I think there's a, a rest of development line that I used as a basis for a hook of a song once. And I can't remember which one it was. I had a song called Sleeping on the Fold Out on my first album that's literally from Seinfeld.
如果这是台电脑，你必须有输入。我的意思是，多阅读、多听、多看电影，所有这些都是输入。我甚至从最奇怪的台词里获得过灵感。我想有一次我用《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）里的一句台词作为歌曲副歌的基础。我不记得是哪一句了。我第一张专辑里有一首歌叫《睡在折叠床上》（Sleeping on the Fold Out），歌词其实来自《宋飞正传》（Seinfeld）。
Remember when, remember, that's about basically, then the chorus of the song is an old fashioned country, like sleeping on the fold out, thanks to me and my big mouth. Why did I say what I said or whatever? Um, you know, your wife basically makes you sleep on the couch and it came from when, when Jerry's like going down to Florida and, and George is like, you know, you can sleep on the fold out. He's like, yeah, God, my back will never be the same, you know, and it's like, oh, that's pretty good country.
记得吗？那首歌的副歌就是那种老派乡村风格，唱着“睡在折叠床上，都怪我这张大嘴”。为什么我说了那些话之类的？嗯，你知道，你老婆基本上让你睡沙发，这源于杰瑞（Jerry）要去佛罗里达，乔治（George）说：“你可以睡在折叠床上。”他说：“天哪，我的背永远好不了了。”你知道，这听起来很有乡村味。
I'll sleep it on the fold out. That's so you, that's so incredibly country. That's one of the great things about country makes it so accessible because it talks about just these, these things, these real life and like me and my big mouth, I got to sleep on the, on the fold out. Um, it's like, you know, you know, this old truck, she, she broke down and now I'm just looking for my dog. Right.
“我睡在折叠床上。”这太像你了，太有乡村味了。这就是乡村音乐的伟大之处，它非常平易近人，因为它谈论的就是这些真实生活中的琐事，比如“都怪我这张大嘴，我得睡在折叠床上”。嗯，就像，“你知道，这辆旧卡车坏了，现在我正到处找我的狗。”对吧。
Hang on. Let me write all this down. Yeah. I mean, this just pours out of him. This pours out of him. But I love it. There's, but it's so, so great. So it makes it so like there, there is that kind of, I don't know, what is it, folk poetry?
等等，让我把这些都记下来。是啊，这些东西就像从他脑子里喷涌而出。这确实是从他脑子里喷出来的。但我喜欢。这太棒了。所以它有一种，我不知道，该怎么说，民谣诗歌的感觉？
Like it, it is like this thing that, and it, and it's sort of the narrative of your life and what's going on and the day to day and obviously some of it's much bigger, but there is that thing that makes it so immediate that people can relate to in the, in its immediacy. It's, it's not esoteric. I had really good teachers in that like one of my songwriting partners is a genius whose father was a songwriter and who did great and his name is Chris Dubois and he always used to just brutally critique my songs in a great way. And he's, he's somebody that we own a publishing company together.
它就像是你生活的叙事，关于正在发生的事情和日常琐事，当然有些主题会更宏大，但正是那种即时感让人们产生共鸣。它并不深奥。我遇到过很好的老师，比如我的一位创作搭档，他是个天才，他父亲也是词曲作者，成就斐然，他叫克里斯·杜波依斯（Chris Dubois）。他过去总是以一种很好的方式严厉地批评我的歌。他也是和我合伙经营出版公司的人。
But he's the kind of guy that's like, don't do that. You wouldn't say that. And that's a big thing with country songs. It's like, you wouldn't say that. So why would you put that in a country song and the best ones, whether you're listening to stuff like the, the old Harlan Howard songs or something from R format and Johnny Cash or anything like that, or even John Prine, who I'd consider practically a country writer in so many ways.
但他就是那种会说“别那样写，你不会那样说话”的人。这对乡村歌曲来说很重要。就像，你不会那样说，那为什么要把它写进乡村歌里呢？最好的作品，无论你听的是哈伦·霍华德（Harlan Howard）的老歌，还是R·福尔曼（R Format）和约翰尼·卡什（Johnny Cash）的作品，甚至是约翰·普莱恩（John Prine）的歌——他在很多方面都被我视为乡村词曲作者。
It's just like, you wouldn't say that. Don't sing it. It's like, that's, that's a big problem. It's like, when you can't put your finger on why you don't like a line in a song, it's usually, oh yeah, I'd never say that. Like there's pet peeves for me of, of songs that'll say, you know, instead of saying it the way you'd say it, they rhyme a word, it's like, you know, snow that's white or something, you know, and it's like, you wouldn't say snow that's white because you would just, it's
就是那种“你不会那样说，就别唱出来”。这是一个大问题。当你无法指出为什么不喜欢歌里的一句词时，通常是因为“哦，对了，我永远不会那样说”。比如我有一些讨厌的歌词，它们不是用你平时说话的方式表达，而是为了押韵强行凑词，比如“白色的雪”之类的，你知道，你不会说“白色的雪”，因为那本来就是
freaking snow. You just, right. What is the, I think, I think anybody would agree, as soon as you start hearing a country song, you know it's a country song, irrespective of the, of the lyrics, there is a, there's a sound to a country song and it's not just a slide guitar. What is, is there an, an element, a component, a, a recipe that, oh no guys, we've got to change it. This sounds too much like a rock song where this sounds too much like a disco song or this
该死的雪。你只会说雪，对吧。我想，任何人都会同意，一旦你开始听一首乡村歌曲，你立刻就能听出来，不管歌词如何，乡村歌曲有一种独特的音色，不仅仅是滑棒吉他。有没有什么元素、成分或配方，让你觉得“哦不，伙计们，我们得改改，这听起来太像摇滚乐了，或者太像迪斯科了，或者这”
like, like, what do you have to have in a country song for it to be in the lane that the expectant audience is looking for? I think you're hitting the nail on the head in one way and that it's, there's always something that makes it there. If you have a rock beat and a lyric about something completely sort of urban, it's not a country song. But if you have a rock beat and you're singing about, I'm taking my baby out into this cornfield tonight.
就像，乡村歌曲里必须有什么，才能让它保持在目标受众期待的轨道上？我觉得你一针见血地指出了这一点，确实总有一些东西让它成为乡村音乐。如果你用摇滚节奏，歌词写的是完全都市化的东西，那它就不是乡村歌曲。但如果你用摇滚节奏，唱的是“今晚我要带我的宝贝去玉米地”，
Right. Yeah. We're gonna lay in the bed of my truck. You could be as heavy metal as you want. It's a country song. Right. You could have a, something where there's a banjo underneath and it's like, well immediately that becomes a little inbred.
对。是的。我们要躺在我的卡车后斗里。你可以把它做得像重金属一样重，它依然是乡村歌曲。对。你可以加点班卓琴伴奏，那听起来就有点“近亲繁殖”的感觉了。
That's good, but there's, but there's not, there's not, there's not a melodic, essential ingredient. Yeah. I think there is, but I'm not sure exactly what. Yeah. I think it's that there's that one thing that feels, and sometimes it's the singer. Like somebody asked Waylon Jennings once, what makes a song country is like, when I sing in its country.
那很好，但并没有一个旋律上的核心要素。是的，我想是有的，但我不太确定具体是什么。是的，我觉得就是那种感觉，有时取决于歌手。就像有人问韦伦·詹宁斯（Waylon Jennings），什么让一首歌成为乡村歌曲，他说：“当我唱的时候，它就是乡村歌曲。”
Yeah. They have something like, yeah, right? Yeah. Well, I tell you right now, and it's like, you could sing, you know, you know, come on baby, I'm living on a prayer and it's like, that's country all of a sudden. Is there a genre of music that you just will not listen to that you just do not like? Well, that was, I was going to say, what would we be surprised? I listened to a lot of other stuff.
是啊。他们有那种感觉，对吧？是啊。我告诉你，你可以唱“来吧宝贝，我正靠祈祷过活”，突然间它就变成乡村风格了。有没有哪种音乐类型是你绝对不会听、完全不喜欢的？嗯，我正想说，我们会感到惊讶吗？我听很多其他类型的音乐。
I listened to less country these days than I did early on in my life. I, you know, I listened to a lot of, I like alt rock. I really do. Like, I like everything from obscure British bands to I love like Dawes, you know what I'm talking about? But they're kind of country, but that like, that's a great, you know, I like Coldplay. I like all that. I like, where do you put Wilco?
我这些年听乡村音乐比早年少多了。我听很多另类摇滚。真的。我喜欢各种音乐，从冷门的英国乐队到像Dawes这样的乐队，你知道我在说什么吗？他们有点乡村味，但那很棒。我喜欢酷玩乐队（Coldplay）。我喜欢所有这些。你把Wilco乐队归在哪一类？
They're, they're sort of a country hybrid, right? Absolutely. I love Wilco. I love Wilco. Do you know that band before, do you like Uncle Tupelo, that band that used to be the Wilco and something that came out of? Yeah. Yeah.
他们算是乡村混合风格，对吧？绝对是。我喜欢Wilco。我喜欢Wilco。你知道那个乐队吗？你喜欢Uncle Tupelo吗？那个Wilco的前身乐队？是啊，是啊。
Absolutely. They freaked me because they get away with little tricks that it's like, oh, I'm going to try to do that kind of thing right there. Tweety's always thinking of something that's like, oh, that's pretty neat. There's like sonic sort of atmospheric sort of soundscape at times, right? And then they'll go right into a, do a banjo sort of typical four, four or something. And, and yeah, that's, it's really interesting. What about, what about other classic like Americana bands like, like REM?
绝对喜欢。他们让我很着迷，因为他们总能用一些小技巧，让我觉得“哦，我也要试着做那种效果”。Tweedy总是在想一些很酷的东西。有时会有那种音效般的氛围感，对吧？然后他们又会直接转入一段典型的四四拍班卓琴演奏。这真的很有趣。那其他经典的美国本土乐队呢，比如R.E.M.？
What would you think? Yeah. Was that the, did you listen to them? Absolutely. Well, they were, yeah. They were in school. So, yeah. I mean.
你怎么看？是啊。你听过他们的歌吗？绝对听过。他们当时在学校。所以，是的。
Where did you go to school? I mean, like college? Yeah. College. I went to Belmont in Nashville. Oh, okay. I moved here to go to Belmont University, but I'm from West Virginia. So, I mean, see, I, I got out of getting beat up in high school by learning how to play
你在哪上的学？大学吗？对，大学。我在纳什维尔的贝尔蒙特大学（Belmont）。哦，好吧。我搬到这里是为了上贝尔蒙特大学，但我来自西弗吉尼亚州。所以，我通过学习弹奏
Clapton and Van Halen stuff on the guitar, you know, so it'd be like, it was like a scene in one of those, in Thriller or something where they're about to beat me up and it's like, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, like whip out of ukulele and you're all set. Absolutely. Yeah. So, so then knowing all that to Shawn's original point, which I cut in on, what will you not listen to? That's a good question.
克莱普顿（Clapton）和范·海伦（Van Halen）的吉他曲，避免了在高中挨揍，你知道，就像《颤栗》（Thriller）里的场景，他们正要揍我，然后我就掏出一把尤克里里，一切就搞定了。绝对是。所以，回到肖恩（Shawn）最初的观点，我刚才打断了你，你不会听什么？这是个好问题。
I don't like steel drum music. I mean, you know what I'm saying? Like that, that immediate, like reggae. I like, I like reggae to a point, but like steel drum music, that's something about that instrument bothers me. Sure. You probably had a bad experience with, with some undercooked chicken, one of those carts. Yeah.
我不喜欢钢鼓音乐。我的意思是，你懂我的意思吗？那种即时的，像雷鬼音乐。我喜欢雷鬼，但到一定程度，钢鼓音乐那种乐器的声音让我很烦。当然。你可能在某个小摊吃过没煮熟的鸡肉，有过糟糕的经历。是啊。
Right. Yeah. A little, you know, rhino virus on a cruise and steel drums are never the same. Rhino virus. Where are you on that, that, that, that yelling, the yelling rock? What's it called? Oh, death metal. They're screaming.
对。在游轮上得了鼻病毒，从此钢鼓音乐就再也不一样了。鼻病毒。你对那种吼叫的摇滚怎么看？叫什么来着？哦，死亡金属。他们在尖叫。
Yes. Death metal. You love that, right? Well, I don't, but here's the thing that's fun about it. Hey, Pops. Captain Jason holding a newspaper as a car goes by and his neighbor would go, turn down that yelling, turn down that rocket. I do something really fun with my kids.
是的，死亡金属。你喜欢那个，对吧？嗯，我不喜欢，但有趣的地方在于，嘿，老爸。杰森船长拿着报纸，一辆车经过，邻居会说：“把那吼叫声关小点，把那摇滚乐关小点。”我和孩子们玩过一个很有趣的游戏。
So there's liquid metal as a channel on serious and then there's fifties on five. Okay. So if you take on your car dial and you put liquid metal and fifties on five side by side and you save them on your presets, go back and forth. It's the greatest entertainment in the history of life because it's like all the chapel bells were rang death, death, death, death, death. You go back and they were singing in the square, you know, I'm gonna kill you baby. I'm gonna rip your guts out and you go back and forth and it's fantastic.
天狼星卫星广播（Sirius）上有个频道叫Liquid Metal，还有一个叫Fifties on Five。如果你在车里的收音机上把这两个频道设为相邻的预设，然后来回切换，那是史上最棒的娱乐节目。因为就像所有的教堂钟声都在敲响“死亡、死亡、死亡”。然后你切回去，他们正在广场上唱着“我要杀了你，宝贝，我要掏出你的内脏”，然后你来回切换，真是太棒了。
Are they old enough to love that? How old are they? They're 11 and 13. Yeah. We've been doing that for years though. They would howl. Like every now and then we get one where it was like, you know, something about, you know, the sweet little angel and then all of a sudden die.
他们够大到喜欢这个了吗？他们多大了？11岁和13岁。是啊。我们已经玩了好几年了。他们会大笑。有时我们会听到那种，你知道，关于“甜蜜的小天使”，然后突然变成“去死”。
Yeah. Now is that a boy and a girl? Girl and a boy. Two boys. Two boys. How is that? 11 and 13. That sounds boy, two boys.
是啊，是一个男孩和一个女孩吗？女孩和男孩。两个男孩。两个男孩。那怎么样？11岁和13岁。听起来是两个男孩。
Have you, how many times you've been in the emergency room? Let's see. Three. Three times. Three in total. What about you, Will? Are you there yet? Oh, we've been a few times.
你进过多少次急诊室？让我想想。三次。总共三次。你呢，威尔（Will）？你还没到那一步吗？哦，我们去过几次。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We've had multiple stitches. You're past three. I've had multiple times with my 11 year old with Archie where he's like getting stitches on his head and his toe and I'm having to help hold him down and he's looking at me
是啊。缝过好几次针。你超过三次了。我11岁的儿子阿奇（Archie）缝过好几次针，头上、脚趾上，我得帮着按住他，他看着我，
going, why? I'm like, it's heartbreaking, man. How many you have, Jason? You have? I got two girls, 13 and eight. Oh man, that's not easy. Only one emergency room visit. And that was for yourself, right?
问“为什么？”我当时心都碎了，伙计。你有几个孩子，杰森？我有两个女儿，13岁和8岁。天哪，那可不容易。只去过一次急诊室。那是为你自己去的，对吧？
Yes. Yes. For my broken heart because they weren't listening, Shawn. I get it. I get it. No, but that 13 year old's really starting to run her mouth. So we could end up back there pretty, pretty soon. I get it though.
是的。因为我心碎了，因为她们不听话，肖恩。我懂，我懂。不，但那个13岁的孩子开始顶嘴了。所以我们很快可能又会回到那里。但我懂。
My 13 year old, the boy, it's like there was this day where it switched. It was like, wait a minute, what the heck is that? It's at 11, right? It's at 11, isn't it? Well with him, it was like he turned 13 and Kim was out of town and so we had had the best night. I mean, we had done this thing called lava charging, which is this game we play where I'm tossing them in the pillows and we've been doing that since they were two.
我13岁的儿子，有一天突然变了。就像，等一下，那是什么鬼？是在11岁的时候，对吧？是在11岁，不是吗？对他来说，就像他刚满13岁，金（Kim）出城了，我们度过了最棒的一晚。我们玩了一个叫“熔岩冲锋”的游戏，就是我把他们扔到枕头上，从他们两岁起我们就这么玩。
And then I made them warm milk before bed, we did something else and then they asked if they could do one more thing, which was like one other fun thing we do. And I said, no, it's bedtime. And he just went like immediately just like, you know what, dad? It is so stressful when mom's gone and I can't wait for her to come back. And I, oh my God, I was like, this 13 year old came out and I went, oh, I get it. Look, I know what you're doing. And he went, what do you mean?
然后我给他们做了热牛奶，我们还做了别的事，然后他们问能不能再玩一个游戏，就是我们玩的另一个有趣的游戏。我说不行，该睡觉了。他立刻就说：“你知道吗，爸爸？妈妈不在的时候压力太大了，我真希望她快点回来。”我当时，天哪，我心想，这个13岁的孩子怎么这样，我说：“哦，我懂。听着，我知道你在干什么。”他问：“你什么意思？”
And I said, I was you and it's not going to work. I said, here's why it's not going to work. You're trying to hurt my feelings. You know what? I love more than anything, Huck. I love being with you guys. And guess what? I would not say to you, I can't wait for mom to get back.
我说：“我以前也这样，这招没用。”我说：“我告诉你为什么没用。你想伤害我的感情。你知道吗？我最爱你了，哈克（Huck）。我喜欢和你们在一起。猜怎么着？我才不会对你说‘我真希望妈妈快点回来’。”
I wouldn't say that because I love this time together and I said, and you're trying to hurt me and it's not working because it didn't hurt. I said, I know what you're doing. And he went, he started crying and he was like, I'm so sorry. I'm so beautiful. And I was like, okay, I'm Andy Griffith folks. I am Andy Griffith. You know what?
我不会那样说，因为我珍惜我们在一起的时光。我说：“你在试图伤害我，但这没用，因为我没受伤。”我说：“我知道你在干什么。”他开始哭，说：“对不起，我太混蛋了。”我说：“好吧，我是安迪·格里菲斯（Andy Griffith），伙计们。我是安迪·格里菲斯。”你知道吗？
That's right. Brett, I've got a suggestion. Maybe this is a different way. Next time he does that, you go, hey, you know what, man, you hurt my feelings and you need to know when I get low and my feelings are hurt, I write a hit song and you just made me millions of dollars. So go ahead and keep doing it because I am going to write a heartbreak song. I'm going to try that tactic next.
没错。布拉德（Brad），我有个建议。也许这是另一种方式。下次他再那样，你就说：“嘿，你知道吗，伙计，你伤害了我的感情，你需要知道，当我情绪低落、感情受伤时，我会写出一首热门歌曲，你刚才让我赚了几百万美元。所以继续吧，因为我要写一首心碎的歌。”下次我要试试这招。
Yeah. Sean and Scotty don't have to worry about any of this stuff, do you? Yeah. No, Scotty and I don't have kids. Like my favorite quote, I think I ever read in my life was I'd rather regret not having kids than have them and regret it later. So I, it's healthy. That's good.
是啊。肖恩和斯科蒂（Scotty）不用担心这些事，对吧？是啊。不，斯科蒂和我没有孩子。我读过最喜欢的一句话是：我宁愿后悔没要孩子，也不愿要了孩子后又后悔。所以，这很健康。那很好。
Right. Right. But yeah, we always talk about having kids and I'm like 90% there. He's probably like 85% there, but neither of us are 100% because if he was like, oh my God, I want kids so bad, I'd be like, at least there's one of us I can hand the child off to right because they want that, you know, that's, that's what in laws or nannies or a night nurse or, or school, that's what schools forced daycare until about 10th grade. Right.
对。对。但我们总是谈论要孩子，我大概有90%的意愿。他大概有85%，但我们都没有100%。因为如果他表现得“天哪，我太想要孩子了”，我会说：“至少我们中间有一个人可以把孩子交给他照顾，对吧？”因为他们想要那个，你知道，那是姻亲、保姆、夜班护士，或者学校，那是学校强制的日托，直到10年级。对吧。
Right. Right. Sean and I have worked on a couple of shows together. My kids come and visit a lot and he'd just be like, Jesus, these kids, can you just do it? No, I do not. I do not. The thing about all of what I just said is I absolutely, truly do love kids.
对。对。肖恩和我合作过几个节目。我的孩子们经常来探班，他就会说：“天哪，这些孩子，你能管管吗？”不，我不会。我不会。关于我刚才说的所有这些，我绝对、真心爱孩子。
No, he does. I just think they're awesome. I just don't. It really seems like it. Yeah. Sean, why don't you just wait a little while longer, you know, start when you're 60 maybe when the kids, if they're the little people, they're the smaller ones that are, yeah, can you guys have pictures or just get on it, Sean?
不，他确实爱。我只是觉得他们很棒。我只是不……看起来确实如此。是啊。肖恩，你为什么不再等一会儿呢？也许60岁再开始，当孩子们……如果他们是小人儿，他们是小一点的，是啊，你们能有照片吗？或者赶紧行动吧，肖恩？
You're going to love it and you got time to get your head around it while the kid learns how to walk and talk. It lets the parents to become parents. The adults. Look, I have nineties in nephews. I have God kids. I love all of them. I love spending time with them.
你会爱上它的，你有时间在孩子学习走路和说话的时候做好心理准备。这让父母成为父母。成年人。看，我有侄子侄女。我有教子。我爱他们所有人。我喜欢和他们在一起。
Name one of them. Name one of them right now. Well, you know what? Do not play these games with me. Yeah. Sean, do you work for JPL or is that just a hat? I moonlight. I moonlight there.
说出一个名字。现在就说出一个。好吧，你知道吗？别跟我玩这些游戏。是啊。肖恩，你是为喷气推进实验室（JPL）工作，还是那只是顶帽子？我那是兼职。我在那里兼职。
I build, I built the rover. The Mars rover. Oh, cool. Yeah. I had a hand in that. No, I'm a fan of astronomy, sci-fi, science, all that kind of stuff. So I have gone on a couple tours at the Jet Propulsion Laboratory in Pasadena, California because it's close.
我制造了火星探测器。哦，酷。是啊。我参与了。不，我是天文学、科幻、科学这些东西的粉丝。所以我去过加州帕萨迪纳的喷气推进实验室参观过几次，因为离得很近。
And I actually did see the rover before it went to Mars. So it was wild to see in person a piece of spacecraft that actually is on another planet right now. Yeah. You must crush ass. What a catch. What a catch you are. Yeah.
我确实在探测器去火星之前见过它。所以能亲眼看到一个现在正在另一个星球上的航天器，真是太疯狂了。是啊。你一定很受欢迎。真是个抢手货。你真是个抢手货。是啊。
With that intro, you could become the president of the JIS Propulsion Laboratory. It's just incredible. Who says I'm not? Jesus. And here's our expert and propellant. JIS Propulsion Laboratory. You know, Brad, I wanted to say this is the worst segue. I just want to say hi to all the kids out there who are looking for inspiration listening
有了那个开场白，你都能当喷气推进实验室的主席了。真是不可思议。谁说我不是？天哪。这是我们的推进专家，喷气推进实验室。你知道，布拉德，我想说这是最烂的过渡。我只是想向所有正在听我们播客、寻找灵感的孩子们问好。所以布拉德，你有这么多热门歌曲，你是个大人物。我已经停止自我吹嘘了，好像我是这里的喷气推进专家一样。这就是我要说的，你生活中的喷气推进方面。不，我想说的是，你做了所有这些贡献，然后你开始，好吧，首先，你开始和佩顿·曼宁（Peyton Manning）拍这些广告。我想知道，你们在拍这些广告之前就是朋友吗？因为它们变得无处不在，我觉得这是一个大活动，但那让你接触到了那些不一定熟悉你的音乐或那种类型的人。那是怎么发生的？而且，我一直想知道，你们是哥们吗？我们当时不太熟。我们在一些场合见过面，我们互相很欣赏，我喜欢他。我的意思是，我和他接触过一些，他真的是个喜剧天才，说真的，我是认真的。我不是随口说说。
to our podcast. So Brad, so you have all these hits, you're a huge, you're a huge story. I've stopped stroking my ego like I'm the JIS Propulsion expert on here. This is what I'm getting to, the JIS Propulsion aspect of your life. No, what I wanted to say was, but you do all this stuff and contribute and then you become and then you start, well, first of all, you start doing these ads with Peyton Manning. I want to know, were you guys friends before you guys started doing these ads because they became OmniPresent and I think that that's, it's a big campaign, but that's something
欢迎来到我们的播客。Brad，你有很多热门作品，你的故事非常精彩。我不再自吹自擂说我是这里的JIS推进专家了。这就是我想说的，关于你生活中JIS推进的那一面。不，我想说的是，你做了这么多贡献，然后你开始，首先，你开始和Peyton Manning一起拍广告。我想知道，你们在拍这些广告之前就是朋友吗？因为这些广告变得无处不在，我觉得这是一个很大的宣传活动，但那是...
that like opened you up to people who weren't necessarily familiar with that, with your music or that genre. How did that happen? And were you, I always wanted to know, were you guys buddies? We didn't know each other that well. We'd seen each other at some things and we're very complimentary and I liked him. I mean, I'd been around him some, he, he's a comedic genius, honestly, I mean that. And I'm not throwing that out lightly.
这让你被那些不一定熟悉你的音乐或那种流派的人所认识。这是怎么发生的？我一直想知道，你们是好哥们吗？我们之前不太熟。我们在一些场合见过面，互相都很欣赏，我也很喜欢他。我的意思是，我和他接触过一些，他真的是个喜剧天才，我是认真的，我不是随口说说。
He really, I've never seen anybody who's from the sports world that understands that, like he does. He understands. I've long said he's the best comedic athlete of all time, without a doubt, I think. His comedy chops are just, he knows who he is. And so the way it came about was nationwide is on your side. They're on our side. They had this idea for a campaign that was really fun.
我从未见过任何来自体育界的人像他那样理解喜剧。他懂。我早就说过，他是史上最棒的喜剧运动员，毫无疑问。他的喜剧天赋，他很清楚自己是谁。所以事情是这样发生的，Nationwide保险公司站在你这边。他们站在我们这边。他们有一个非常有趣的活动创意。
That was, what if there's more to the song than you know? And they're like, we want you to write like a verse about a guy that, you know, backs his RV over the flower bed after he buys it for retirement. And so I did that and when did some commercials for them, just with a guitar, like, and in passing when we were sitting there, they said, what else do you think we could do with this? And I said, well, I think what would be fun is if Peyton basically starts telling me how to do this. And the next thing you know, they've booked a session and the first ads we did were me
那就是：如果这首歌背后的故事比你知道的更多呢？他们说：“我们想让你写一段歌词，关于一个家伙，你知道，在他退休买了一辆房车后，把它倒车压坏了花坛。”所以我写了，并为他们拍了一些广告，只用了一把吉他。在拍摄间隙，我们坐在那里时，他们说：“你觉得我们还能用这个做什么？”我说：“嗯，我觉得如果佩顿开始教我怎么做，会很有趣。”结果他们预订了一场录音，我们拍的第一支广告就是我在录音室里。我唱了一句，我说：“你觉得怎么样？”他就像：“更好，但过来。”他开始在镜头前教我怎么唱歌之类的。这比我能想象到的还要有喜剧效果。它们很棒。真的很好。我记得他上《周六夜现场》（SNL）的时候，我前妻也在那，他表现得比所有人预期的都要好得多。
in the studio. I sort of sang like a line and I'm like, what do you think he's like better, but come here. And he starts like teaching me how to sing on the camera and everything. And it was way more comedy gold than I could have even imagined. They're great. They're really great. I remember when he came on SNL and my ex-wife is on there and he was just like, he was just so much better and so much more than everybody expected.
他太搞笑了。我记得他在那里的表现。但总之，你做了那些广告，它们非常成功。那有没有改变，你注意到有什么变化吗？是啊。是啊。这很有趣，因为当你拍广告时，这是一种冒险，威尔，你知道，因为它们真的会适得其反，当广告结束时，人们可能会对你少了几分尊重。
He was hilarious. I remember him on there. But anyway, so you do those things and they're huge. And then did that kind of like change, did you notice a change, like a shift? Yeah. Yeah. And it's interesting because it's a risky thing when you do a commercial, as you know, Will, because they can really backfire and people can look at you with less respect when
你懂我的意思吗？哦，我很想在这里停一下，盘点一下威尔的广告生涯。好吧，我们要按字母顺序来吗？听着，这很有趣。你知道他们都在说什么，没有所谓的“卖身”，只有“买入”。我们马上回来。
it's over. You know what I mean? Oh, I'd love to pull over here for one second and go down Will's commercial cannon right now. Well, should we do it alphabetically? Listen, that's a lot of fun. You know what they're all saying, there's no selling out, there's only buying in. We'll be right back.
哇。是啊。但这就是问题所在，当你签约参加这些活动时，你只是，就像，你希望它能像你期望的那样好。最后，很少有这么有趣的事情。就像我们拍摄这些广告时，无论如何都非常有趣，我们玩得很开心，而且很多都是即兴发挥的。比如有一段我们开车在路上，他试图教我怎么写
Wow. Yeah. That's the thing though is when you sign up for one of these campaigns, you're just, it's like, you hope it's going to be as great as you hope. And then in the end, it's like, it's rare that it's something that's that much fun. Like when we film these, it's so much fun anyway, and we have a ball and then, and a lot of them are ad-libbed. Like there's one where we're going down the road and he's trying to tell me how to write
一首歌，我们在那辆巴士上的那一段，全是即兴的，那是最好的广告之一。这真的是我愿意做的事，别告诉他们，但我甚至愿意免费做，因为它太有趣了，但我不会那么做。看得出来，你们看起来也像老朋友。我的意思是，看起来你们确实有交情。我们现在是了。是啊。
a song and that one where we're on that bus, that was all ad-libbed and that's one of the better ones. It's just really, it's really something I would do, don't tell them this, but I would do it for free because it's so much fun, but I'm not going to. You can tell, and you guys, and you guys seem like old friends too. I mean, it really reads that you guys have a period. And we are now. Yeah.
我们真的是。疫情期间最让我大开眼界的一刻是，在一个周六晚上，我正走去农场的谷仓，我低头看手机，收到佩顿的一条短信。他说：“嘿，现在加入这个Zoom会议。”我点进去，加入会议，他说：“好吧，布拉德，佩顿在那儿，还有一群橄榄球运动员，还有一个新闻主播和其他人。”他说：“好吧，从通讯录里找一个名人，现在把他拉进来。”所以我给达里乌斯（Darius）发了短信，问：“嘿，你在干嘛？”他说：“我在看R·凯利（R. Kelly）的纪录片。”我说：“休息一下，我告诉你结局。”然后洗个澡，然后，是啊，对吧。所以他加入了，然后丹·帕特里克（Dan Patrick）和凯文·哈特（Kevin Hart）也加入了。这是一个周六晚上，大家都在Zoom上喝酒，名人，疯狂又奇怪。
We really are. Like one of the most eye-opening moments of this pandemic has been on a Saturday night, I'm walking down to the barn on our farm and I'm just like, my phone, I look down, there's a text from Peyton. He's like, hey, jump on this zoom right now. And I go, boom. And I jump in this zoom and he's like, okay, Brad Peyton was there and it's him and a bunch of football players and he's like, and a newscaster and somebody else and he's like, okay, get
这太棒了。就像，哦，这真的很疯狂。这些人是我以前在周六晚上绝不会以这种方式聚在一起的。这很有趣。是啊。我觉得人们在这一切期间发现了很多新的聚会、交流和工作方式。
one famous person from Rolodex and put him in right now. And so I texted Darius and I'm like, Hey, what are you doing? He's like, I'm watching the R Kelly documentary. And I'm like, take a break, I'll tell you how it ends. And then shower and then yeah, right. So he jumps on and then Dan Patrick jumps on and Kevin Hart. And this was a Saturday night and it was everybody having like a zoom drinking session, famous people, crazy weird.
我想，我希望，还是有一些一线希望的。肖恩和我对我们正在做的事情玩得很开心。我的意思是，我们所在的那个群体真的很有趣。这是最棒的。这是假装杀人的东西。假装杀人。是啊。但肖恩还没给出一个好的解释，为什么他不能
And it was awesome. It was like, oh, this is, this is really wild. These are people out of never ever just hung out with on a Saturday night in another way probably. And it was a lot of fun. Yeah. I think people discovered a lot of new ways to hang out, communicate, work during all this.
今晚加入。他到底在干什么？我知道，我同意。好吧。你想知道真相吗？显然，你的电又停了。肖恩的电停了24小时，你会觉得这家伙，真是不可思议。疫情和那比起来简直不算什么。
There are some silver linings, I think, I hope. And Sean and I are having a ball with what we're doing. I mean, that, that whole group we're in is really fun. It's the best. This is the fake, fake killing people stuff. Fake killing people. Yeah. But it was, Sean hasn't really given yet again, a good explanation as to why he can't get
肖恩，你为什么不买个发电机？是啊，没错。他们编出来的。你为什么不待在那儿，管好你自己的事呢？所以。有道理。有道理。不。
on tonight. Like what is he possibly doing? I know, I agree. Okay. Do you want to know for real? Obviously, your power going out again. Sean's power went out for 24 hours and you'd think that this guy, it's unbelievable. That the pandemic was nothing compared to that.
斯科蒂有一些朋友，他有一群朋友，他们都有点像“星际迷航”迷（Trekkies），他们都喜欢，你知道，所以我叫他们“苹果饺子帮”。所以他今晚要和“苹果饺子帮”开Zoom会议。天哪，又一次，那一定是在互相嘲讽。好吧。你们是我认识的最书呆子的同性恋。1000%。而且一直都是。
Why don't you get a generator, Sean? Yeah, that's right. They make it up. Why don't you, why don't you stay there and mind your own business? So the. Fair enough. Fair enough. No.
不同品种。是啊。所以当你思考完科学、太空和所有这些东西后，就是“星际迷航”了。你们保持着同样的主题。是啊。好吧，现在，是啊，我不是“星际迷航”迷。我更像是“星球大战”迷。
Scotty has some friends that he, a group of friends that he has that they're all kind of like Trekkies and they all like, you know, so I call them the apple dumpling gang. So he has a zoom meeting with the apple dumpling gang tonight. Boy, once again, just the ass crushing that must go on. All right. You guys are the nerdiest gay guys I've ever known. 1,000 percent. Consistently too.
是啊。我们怎么敢，对吧？你只是喜欢火箭之类的东西。是啊，没错。所以布拉德，我会和大家一起去钓鱼，但我可能会带上一堆科幻DVD，一堆“星球大战”DVD，然后你会穿着角色扮演服装，星球大战角色扮演。是啊。没错。
Different breed. Yeah. So after you're done thinking about science and space and all that stuff, then it's to the trek. You keep it on, on the same sort of theme. Yeah. Well, now, yeah, I am not a Trekkie. I'm more like a Star Wars person.
这是在主持德累斯顿的卢克（Dresden's Luke）。你们有没有做过那种，那种角色扮演，两个不同的世界，星球大战对战星际迷航，光剑对决？那太棒了。如果我能拍到你穿着……是啊。是啊。我们其实不用真正的光剑。
Yeah. How dare us, right? You just into rockets and stuff. Yeah, right. So Brad, I'll go fishing with all the guys, but I'll probably bring a bunch of sci-fi DVDs, a bunch of Star Wars DVDs and you'll be in cosplay, Star Wars cosplay. Yeah. That's right.
我们用别的东西。我敢打赌你不用。说到这里。是啊。谢谢，肖恩。谢谢你毁了一切。哦，那个叫我“精子推进实验室”的家伙说的话。你是主席。
It's hosting Dresden's Luke. Do you guys ever do like a, like a, like a cosplay, like a two different worlds, the Star Wars versus Star Trek, like lightsaber battle? That would be great. If I could get a video of you in sky. Yeah. Yeah. We don't actually use the actual lightsabers.
没错。我可不会随便把那些帽子发给别人。布拉德，你一直是个非常、非常友善的人，非常有风度。我玩得很开心。非常感谢你做这些。我很荣幸，很荣幸能和你们两位交谈。这真是。我很期待我们未来的友谊，还有我们的道奇队比赛。
We use other things. I'll bet you don't. On that note. Yeah. Thanks, Sean. Thanks for ruining everything. Oh, said the guy who called me jizz propulsion laboratory. You're the president.
我们绝对会去看一场道奇队的比赛，无论如何。你多久来一次洛杉矶？我们两个去看比赛。太棒了。嗯，在典型的，我要假装没听见他刚才说的话，在典型的时间框架内，我们可能一个月至少来一次，待一周。好吧。是啊。
That's right. I don't just hand those hats out. Brad, you've been a very, very nice man, a very good sport. I've had fun. Thank you very much for doing this. I'm honored to, honored to talk to two of you guys. It's been. I'm looking forward to our, to our, our friendship coming up in our, our Dodger games.
我们经常在那边，但我一直去。所以我们会去，我们会去聚聚。是啊。是啊。我们可能得等上一阵子，但至少我们有这个，对吧？我们有我们的Zoom会议。我们有我们的播客剧集，还有未来的计划。是啊。
We are definitely going to a Dodger game one way or another. How often are you out here in LA? Two of us at a game. Amazing. Well, on a, on a typical, I'm going to pretend I didn't hear him say that on a typical like timeframe, we'd probably once a month for a week at least. All right. Yeah.
还有什么比这更好的呢，伙计们？手搭在一起，你看我最后以一个真正积极的基调结束，而不是你刚才说的那些精子之类的东西。威尔，顺便说一句，即使在最好的时候，如果杰森会把手伸出来去碰别人的手，他绝对会把它缩回去，缩回去，还要用袖子包着。你得知道这一点，布拉德，布拉德，你会看到的，当你们开始聚在一起时，他会，如果你去碰某人，他会，一旦你去桌子旁坐下，他就去洗手间洗手，出来的时候就像要去动手术一样。他把手洗到手肘。我的意思是，而且，而且，你不能。我把椅子踢开，他踢椅子。我再也不会碰菜单了。所以我得先点菜，然后，然后去洗手间。嘿，我和你完全一样。
We're out there a lot, but I go all the time. So we'll go, we'll go hang out. Yeah. Yeah. We may have to wait for a while, but at least we've got this, right? We've got our zoom session. We've got our podcast episode and, and plans for the future. Yeah.
我也不会碰菜单。顺便说一句，既然我已经见到杰森了，我对他有一个意见。你是，你是《霹雳游侠》（Knight Rider）的嘉宾吗？是的，先生。是啊。我开了15号那辆车。我太高兴了。那件事发生时我和你一样大，我当时气死你了。
What's better than that, y'all? Hands in, you see the way I ended on a real up note like that instead of the jizz stuff you were going with. Will, by the way, even, even in the best of times, as if Jason would put his hand into touch somebody else's hand, there's no way it'd be bald up, be bald up with a sleeve over it. You got to know this, Brad, Brad, you're going to see this and when you guys start hanging out, he'll go, if you go to get somebody, he goes as soon as you go to sit down at the
一个孩子竟然能做那种事。很棒的一周，对吧？是啊。对我来说是一个非常快的“是”。我敢打赌。我到现在还为此感到难过。你像我一样看电视看了这么久。
table, he goes in, he goes to the bathroom to wash his hands and he comes out like he's going into surgery. He washed his hands to the elbow. I mean, and, and, and you can't. I kicked the chair out and it kicks the chair. I won't touch the menu anymore. So I got to order first, then, then go to the boil. Hey, I'm exactly with you.
我们还有很多事要涵盖。我不会带收音机去我们的比赛。这是我的承诺。那会很刻薄，真的很刻薄。那对我来说意义重大。哇。好吧，那让你感觉如何？嗯，是啊。
I won't touch the menu either. By the way, I have one bone to pick with Jason now that I've met him. You were the, were you a guest on Knight Rider? Yes, sir. Yeah. I drove the kick car 15. I was so happy. I was your age when that happened and I was so pissed at you.
肖恩，我就和你待在一起，假装我不知道体育运动的存在。你把那个界外球还给我，我再带你去看一场比赛。我们一起看《曼达洛人》（The Mandalorian）第二季。好吧，谢谢，布拉德。伙计，你真是个好人。谢谢你来这里。你也是，威尔。这太棒了，我们很快会再见。
That a kid got to do that. A great week. Right. Yeah. It was a very quick yes for me. I bet. I'm just so upset about it still. You've been watching TV as long as I have.
我会把你们的联系方式发给对方。怎么样？天哪，谢谢，威利。谢谢，威尔。这真的很酷。表达方式也很酷。我会做到的。我会做到的。
We got stuff to cover. I'm not going to bring the radio for our game. That's my promise. That'll be really, that'd be really mean. That would mean a lot to me actually. Wow. Well, how does it make you feel? Well, yeah.
我得到了所有酷的东西。我把它放在这里出来的纸带上，上面有所有酷的经历。谢谢，布拉德。谢谢，伙计们。上帝保佑你们。祝好运。再见，伙计。祝一切顺利。
Sean, I'll just go hang with you and pretend that I don't know sports exist. You give me that foul ball back and I'll bring you another game. We'll watch the Mandalorian second season. Well, thank you, Brad. Man, you're a prince of a dude. Thanks, man, for coming on here. You too, Will. It's been great and we'll see you soon.
很快再见。再见，伙计。等等，威尔，你不知道我认识布拉德吗？我不知道你们认识。不。哦，是的。而且我不能核实，因为我不想，嘿，我要请个嘉宾，我不想告诉你他是谁，但你认识布拉德·派斯利（Brad Paisley）吗？
I'll put you guys, I'll send you each other's digits. How about that? Boy, thanks, Willie. Thanks, Will. That's really cool. Cool way to put it too. I'm going to make it. I'm going to make it.
对。好吧，你们认识多久了？你知道吗？关于我那个“锣秀”（Gong Show）的所有笑话和段子。我请了布拉德作为嘉宾，他作为评委参加了“锣秀”。而且，告诉大家你是“锣秀”的制片人。是啊。几年前我们重启“锣秀”时，我是执行制片人。
I got all the cool things. I got it on a ticker tape that comes out here with all the cool experience. Thanks, Brad. Thanks, guys. God bless you. Good luck. See you, man. Good luck with everything.
我请了很多人来参加。有些人答应了，有些人拒绝了。事情就是这样。布拉德来了，他表现得太棒了。有些人拒绝了。有些人反复拒绝。哦哦。然后换了号码。
See you soon. Bye, guy. So, wait, Will, did you not know that I knew Brad? I didn't know that you guys knew each other. No. Oh, yeah. And I can't check because I don't want to get like, hey, I'm going to have a guest on. I don't want to tell you it is, but do you know Brad Paisley?
所以，布拉德。别把气氛搞怪了。所以，布拉德像个好人一样来了，就像好人会做的那样。如果你请他帮忙，他会为你做。是啊。这就是，因为他是个好人，他无私，他不，你知道，自私。所以总之，所以，所以，所以。
Right. Well, how long have you guys known each other? You know what? All the bits and all the jokes everybody made about my gong show. I had Brad on as a, he came on as a judge on the gong show. And well, tell people you are a producer of the gong show. Yeah. I executive produced the gong show when we brought it back a couple of years ago.
等一下。你请杰森了吗？哦，就是那种人，你知道，这就是我们获胜的方式。这就是我们赢得二战的方式，因为我们在那方面很无私。然后有些人是英雄，有些人不是。有些人待在家里推铅笔，担心他们自己的，你知道。哦，所以杰森。没关系。
And I asked a lot of people to come and do it. Some people said yes and some people said no. That's how it went. And Brad came on and he was terrific. And some people said no. And some people said no repeatedly. Uh-oh. And then changed their number.
没关系。没关系。没关系。这不相关。有些人待在家里。好吧。总之。有些人待在马里布的海滩上。
So, Brad. Don't make this weird. So, Brad came on like a good, he was a good guy, like a good guy does. Where he'll do something for you if he asks you to do it. Yeah. And that's what, because he's a good person and he's selfless and he's not, you know, selfish. So anyway, so, so, so.
好吧。所以，重点是，重点是。那真是太有趣了。布拉德有多棒？最棒的。我很高兴你们是朋友。还有杰森。我快要成为朋友了。
Wait a minute. Did you ask Jason to do it? Oh, that's the kind of people, you know, and that's, and that's how we won. And that's how we won the world war two because we were just selfless in that way. And then some people were heroes and some people were not. Some people are at home pushing pencils and worried about their own, you know. Oh, so Jason. Doesn't matter.
这真是一场恋爱。我会把他们从你们俩手中抢走。是啊。这真是一场在这里萌芽的恋爱。我们可以探视，对吧？是啊。你们可以，你们感觉到了，对吧？嗯，我，我没疯。
Doesn't matter. Doesn't matter. Doesn't matter. It's unrelated. Some people were at home. Okay. Anyway. Some people at the beach of Malibu.
是啊。是啊。一点也不。如果你预料到会是布拉德，而且你们会相处得这么好，你会不会在之前多做一点“男士修剪”？你会不会把自己收拾得干净一点？我肯定会把头发弄好，那是你肯定能看到的。是啊。
Okay. So, point is, point is. So that was super fun. How great was Brad? The best. I'm so glad that you guys are friends. And Jason. I'm about to be friends.
是啊。男士修剪，我不觉得那是。但只是为了感觉良好，只是为了，如果你感觉更好，它就会显现出来。是啊。我对下面发生的事情感觉很好。不，不，我感觉，我感觉很好。我昨天收紧了很多。好吧。
It's a real love affair. I'll steal them from both of you guys. Yup. It's a real love affair that's blooming here. We can have visitation, right? Yeah. You guys could, you could, you felt that, right? Well, I was, I'm not crazy.
好。为你高兴。让我给你看看。让我把这个摄像头往下倾斜。别。哦哦。哦哦。它来了。
Yeah. Yeah. No, not at all. If you had, if you had anticipated that it was going to be Brad and that you guys were going to get along so well, would you have done a little bit more manscaping before? Would you have cleaned yourself up a little bit? I would have definitely done my hair that you can see for sure. Yeah.
它来了。再见。再见。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Yeah. The manscaping, I don't think it's. But just to feel good, but just so you can, it reads if you feel better. Yeah. I feel great about what's going on down there. No, no, I feel, I feel good. I tightened a lot up yesterday. Okay.
是啊。关于修剪体毛，我不觉得是那样。但只是为了感觉良好，为了让你自己感觉更好。是啊。我对下面发生的事情感觉很好。不，不，我感觉，我感觉很好。我昨天修剪了很多。好的。
Good. Good for you. Let me show you. Let me just tilt this camera down. Let's not. Uh-oh. Uh-oh. Here it comes.
很好。为你感到高兴。让我给你看看。让我把摄像头往下调一点。还是别了。噢噢。噢噢。来了。
Here it comes. Bye. Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
来了。再见。再见。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。